my parents came from nothing they were
like Hustlers so I think I have that in
my blood because I grew up like watching
them hustle and you know my mom went to
night school and became a lawyer both of
my parents are they both worked at Wawa
I think at one time together my mom was
like the manager or something yeah
but I love that you like did not come
from any connections or leg up like how
did you what was your first in like my
whole like introduction into Hollywood
and stuff was so fast like it was almost
like it doesn't happen like that
normally like I auditioned for funny
people which is a Judd Apatow movie that
Adam Sandler of course was in where I
play a stand-up comedian and then I got
Parks and Rec and then I got Scott
Pilgrim all in the same week
um I know that's crazy I know it doesn't
happen like that it was like I can
literally pinpoint like when people are
like what's your big break I'm like
literally like one week when we